[Music]
welcome today we're asking what can
business learn from sport and i'm
delighted to be joined by ken walsh
deals leader at pwc
nigel wilson ceo of legal in general and
alison kerbin author and former sports
editor of the mail on sunday
now even in a turbulent economy many
businesses will be looking for new
opportunities to grow and many will be
looking at deals and investments they
can make sparking talk of a deals lead
recovery
we're going to focus on what makes a
good deal and how deals can be a
catalyst for positive change now alison
i'm going to start with you
because we're trying to learn about what
business can take away from sports deals
and specifically transfers so what makes
a great deal in the transfer market it's
it's a very complicated thing the
transfer market and quite an odd thing
be interesting to see the extent to
which there's resonance in business so
obviously the good deals that are done
are when the manager has taken time to
think what he needs in his team
and gone to find a team find a player
working in a similar team that he can
move over but nine times out of ten it's
just by ronaldo by this player by this
player and it's not i don't think it's a
very good example of how to do deals
lots of pressures and so many voices
wanting different things isn't it you
don't always have to spend the most
money to get the best team you might
spend a lot of money to get a great
player but that doesn't if he's a great
player in a cohesive team and you move
him into a team where he doesn't have
relationships he won't be such a great
player so sometimes it's a much more
complicated thing well alison has been
talking about those short term pressures
that clubs face is that something that
businesses have suffered from
yeah and i think actually there's a lot
of resonates in what allison just said
when i look at deals and transactions
and it was a corporate merger if you
just look at historical financial
performance well is that an indication
of future success
and actually if you're doing a
transaction look at the culture of the
organization you're joining or you're
merging with look at the people
engagement of their employees how well
connected are they with the purpose of
the corporate they're employed by and
what's the customer satisfaction like
what's their innovation pipeline because
actually those are the indicators of
future success it's a bit like looking
at the players on field performance
actually to your point allison how well
does he fit culturally with the team
he's joining or even if i'm looking at a
football team's position the league
table well people say the league never
lies well actually it does in terms of
you looking at likely future success
because actually what's the performance
of the team in terms of goal difference
and shots on target and again you put
that in a business context you say
actually what's the underlying drive of
the business and actually other
financial performance the historical
results we're looking at really
indicative of the future success of that
business and what am i really buying so
it's about looking at an overall picture
yeah i think when it comes to sport you
can be the best striker in the world but
if no one gives you the ball you won't
score so you're a striker in a team
who's never scoring so no one wants to
buy you so your value in the market is
reduced but it's because of the team
you're playing with and you have to take
a little a further look into the whole
culture and system they've got set up
there whereas if you have a player who's
not very good striker but is given the
ball constantly then of course they're
going to score more goals so it's just
it's not the individual it's it's a team
sport and you have to look at the whole
team and i i suggest that's probably the
same thing
you are ceo of legal in general so i
guess
you're like a manager in a sense isn't
it so for you what makes a bad deal many
of the issues that have been raised so
far are
tremendously important for deals culture
we put right at the top because actually
what we want is a cohesive team and we
have an opportunity to blend lots of
internal people with lots of external
people and we can move people around
internally moving from one team to
another team to constantly strengthen
the overall overall teams so we're
looking at a very very big picture
around this but first
is the culture will this group fit with
our organizations because we want to be
a trusted brand to be a trusted brand
you have to have the same values beliefs
and behaviors because that's what builds
great teamwork and if we ha we're not
getting great teamwork we won't deliver
the right financial results over the
long term so we're thinking
5 10 20 even 30 years at times of the
different types of transactions
like in sport where it's often a very
short-term solution and bad deals in
sport are the same as bad deals in
business short-term solutions and people
go crazy for short-term solutions at
times so if we're saying that
revenue and success sometimes can steer
people away from that long-term vision
how can
the financials
then be looked at differently by a
business nigel touched on it actually
it's about shifting from financials to
value in a broader sense and actually
just focusing on short-term financial
return which actually you would argue
the listed sector has a challenge
because there's analysts constantly
looking at what's the quarterly results
or what's the annual results and
actually you want business in nigel's
term to focus on value delivering value
over 5 10 15 20 year horizon and
actually i think one of the things
that's really shifted in the last 12
months the consequences of pandemic is
business stepping back and saying
actually we have an obligation to the
society we live in and actually that
then fosters medium-term value creation
for us as a corporation rather than just
for focusing on the short-term outcome
so whether it's esg net zero climate
change actually business now recognized
and that shifted in the last 12 months
that to deliver value for their own
business as well as for wider society
they need to focus on that as long as
alongside a short-term financial return
and is there evidence that this works
better for businesses
yeah i think there's a lot of evidence
around this i mean
a purpose is what holds companies
together and increasingly those are a
economic and social purpose people want
to do things that are economically
financially but also socially useful on
a big scale and the people who work for
the company want to be part of that
shared success very important that
you're the purpose and that's one of the
things that we've seen in the last
12 18 months i'm sure you've seen it in
lng as well is our people are looking to
us to say actually what is the
organization that i'm working for it's
not just about the salary i'm paying at
the end of the month actually i want to
feel a connection that my purpose
resonates with the corporate purpose and
that you stand for something that i
believe in and actually we're seeing a
lot of corporates and clients changing
those courses emotional engagement is
the highest it's ever been in my career
right now is that and particularly
driven by lots of young people who who
really want to ask you difficult
questions about you know why am i here
why are we doing this what's the overall
objective and if it's a short-term goal
that doesn't really resonate
particularly well with technology and
science are changing so fast now it's
creating unbelievable opportunities for
us all and so the number of deals is
going to get done is going to rise
tremendously because the raw material
money is the cheapest it's ever been for
you know several hundred years and
therefore that's incredibly cheap but
actually getting the other bits of the
ingredients that make things successful
around a deal is increasingly difficult
because things are changing so quickly
and you want to develop the the purpose
and fit the culture together and it's
not about you know simple transactions
anymore we we consider deals in a much
broader context nigel i want to talk
about vision we've touched on it briefly
about the long term versus the short
term how important is this what we're
trying to do is invest in assets
that actually reflect society and
actually people can look around and see
wow this is what i'm invested in i'm
invested in all of these exciting
startup businesses across 20 different
universities in the uk i'm investing in
assets that are transforming the center
of various towns and cities i'm
investing assets that are delivering
affordable housing for people right
across the uk and that links up with the
purpose that we have as an organization
as well so people can have that massive
emotional engagement and it's a
consistency and a consistency a bit like
sports teams not just in a very short
time period but year after year after
year after year well ken what do you
think is driving this more purposeful
approach to deal making is it the
shareholders past experience
you know
the time we're in
i think it's an acceleration we've seen
in the last 12 months i think it was
already there in 2019 pre-pandemic but
actually we've all realized as human
beings we live in a fragile society and
actually we need to do more to embrace
the outcomes we want in the future we
all want a cleaner greener fair more
equitable society historically we have
the view that the government do
education and business does employment
actually if you look at organizations
that employ as many people as we do in
the uk we've got an obligation to
upskill because the world is moving so
fast whether it's technology development
we you know the pandemic has been
tremendous in driving real change and
accelerating change in lots of different
areas i mean it's it's a horrible thing
to happen but it's driven many of us
closer together and identified the
problems you know health inequality is
such a big issue
but part of the solution is for our
firms to step up our efforts in this all
the solutions are there it's about
people collaborating together to deliver
those
solutions and that's about teamwork
and you know going back to the sporting
analogy it's it's multi-disciplinary
teamwork you know the physios have to be
part of the team people in reception it
matters
what they like and how they greet people
when they when they come in the
professional standards that they set and
they themselves
want to move up the career ladder and
there's nothing
better and more motivating than people
within an organization having great peer
examples of people who've made
tremendous progress i think
collaboration is such a pertinent word
especially in sport because we've seen
how
you know managers the shareholders they
have to start listening to the fans
because fans now can galvanize they've
got social media they can put their
opinions out there and and if you don't
listen
they'll let you know not having fans at
matches has really made people realize
how important fans are yeah and how much
it impacts on the game when you don't
have the fans there it's been wonderful
to watch fans coming back and to feel
the atmosphere and to feel the lift you
get when you watch live sport with fans
there and it's very easy to dismiss fans
but you're only there because of them
you only exist
as a sports team because people want to
watch you and the minute they don't it's
all over the minute they stop buying the
shirts the minute they stop caring and i
think we they've been dismissed in the
past and that's that'll be a real change
that happens now there's been much more
thinking about how important fans are
from the club's point of view also we
have
fans rising up against
um team management making kind of
decisions to move off into the uh the
super league and i think
that was a real moment wasn't it when
you saw the fans
really feeling very strongly and feeling
empowered to express how they felt and
then the the withdraw the climb down
from that okay let's talk about the
importance of data how are businesses
using data to
evaluate their acquisition targets the
reality now is we live in a world that's
awash with data data is tracking our
everyday movements and actually
increasingly in evaluating acquisition
targets for our clients we're looking at
a whole range of data whether it's
customer engagement sentiment analysis
from the internet employee engagement
understanding their r d and innovation
pipeline because actually that alongside
the financial results you put those data
sets together and everything else that's
out there you can get a much more better
picture of
future performance likely future
performances and use those data sets in
a way that determines how the business
will optimize its performance post deal
and continue to grow and accelerate and
improve employment prospects for those
that employees in the communities
operates in and what do you think nigel
you know are they vital you know do you
look at them in your business no
absolutely you know nps scores employee
engagement scores sit right at the heart
of the business because they're
reflecting things that really matter to
us as a firm and you know financial
performance is just a part of it
definitely the others feed into the
financial performance and so i totally
agree with what ken said now nigel i'm
going to come to you for the last
thought
will business remain committed to this
more purposeful approach even if there's
you know changes in the economy yes yes
yes and i think we saw the economy
changing and actually lots of businesses
stepped up and lots of people within
those businesses stepped up because
you've got the raw material the money
we've got the capability we understand
the technology and the science we can
put on the data analytics we can put all
of this together to deliver incredible
solutions for society and we as business
leaders want to do that and our people
want us to do it and there's a real
society societal need for do for doing
that well this has been a fascinating
discussion and i'd like to thank our
guests for sharing their insights and i
hope you found this as interesting as i
have